possible discret quand même nous sommes
allés avec jean-françois le cac et
olivier minne filmé à montmartre une
journée de michou comment est-ce que
cela se passe depuis le matin lorsque
michaud se réveille au pied du sacré
coeur jusqu'au soir au moment où michou
accueille tout son petit monde au
cabaret rue des martyrs images reportage
paris s'éveille et du haut de sa butte
montmartre baigne dans les dernières
bulles de champagne qui s'étiole face au
jour le vent montmartre un village dans
paris qui compte une institution chère
au coeur de tous un prince de la fête
le roi de la nuit dans les choux tous
les matins il dit c'est moi le premier
bonjour c'est pour le souscripteur est
un petit alors dit bonjour vous avez
retourné
mais je vous dise nous de quoi sera fait
votre journée encore un discret et bien
je vous propose je me propose de me
suivre
voilà ma corde et de tous les matins
tous les matins j'ai heureusement qui
sert à mes jolies plantes que j'en
arrive à m'installer d'implanter et je
suis arrivé mais billère techniciens
arrosent les membres estime oui c'est
l'extraordinaire quand même d'avoir
d'avoir ça j'avoue je suis gâté c'est
mon petit jardin à moi je suis très
content mais je prends mon temps après
mange très bien ici oui zut je vais à
s'occuper aujourd'hui vous me rappelez
vous me rappelez dans juste après juste
après le déjeuner je vous embrasse la
green
une fois les rendez vous pris place à
l'amitié au déjeuner conviviaux comme
celui qui chante ou les organiser vous
envie c'est le coup de coeur michou
entend siam a préparé par une super
famille certains riches d'une part une
porte-parole
moi je supplie qu'avec 2 c est sous la
protection du sacré-coeur la flamiche et
le reste du déjeuner auront un franc
succès auprès des amis de michou avec
lui il n'y a pas d'heure pour faire la
fête
et pour la digestion rien de tel qu'une
petite balade dans ce monde martrou mais
je suis se sentent partout comme chez
lui il est vrai que ce ne sont pas les
amis qui manque à cet homme au coeur
grand comme paris de dani un grand
personnage de moment qui vers l'équipe
l'équipe et d'edouard tarlier doute ou
autonomie sous le moment
la place du tertre où ces bistrots
chaleureux c'est plus beau qu'un endroit
fameux toit et ventes ont fait honneur
la parade village 1
le lapin agile l'antre divin
d'inoubliables droit merveilleux dans
laquelle tant d'artistes se produisirent
que mme annie girardot ou claude nougaro
espèce de lâche marc edwards on vient te
voir du népal a jamais joli un bon
déjeuner tout cas tout fait de l'équipe
biche soya tout le monde qui est la fage
hantise va revenir ou pas ce débat ça va
revenir
mais c'est la constance et la
consécration des ans les marches du
sacré coeur pour moi 18 bombarde quoi
l'adoption et quand la nuit couvre à
nouveau de son manteau étoiles et la
ville lumière dans les coulisses les
artistes aux affaires rien n'est laissé
à la rue près la transformation sera
parfait pendant que michou en août
attentionné reçoit les premiers
arrivants un étage plus bas
la magie s'opère déjà le spectacle et la
fête peuvent commencer
merci lucho
coc
ah oui mais quoi